we're gonna matching it I know to look
for a prom right now yeah do you prompt
Oh
Blake you jealous yeah bleep what's up
now [ __ ]
Oh got your girl on TV he the voice
coach is poked fun at a noticeably
absent Blake Shelton who was backstage
getting ready to perform on Monday show
how much fun is it for you going to see
your man in his element up there on
stage I've learned so much about heart
your heart in music just by listening to
a lot of this country music so I'm
excited for Blake the song tonight is a
great song and he's an amazing performer
singer the way he is such a nonchalant
performer and your and I mean in the
greatest way know in the greatest way
like he's so at ease no matter where
whether he's just like playing around I
think he doesn't care about sounding
good which is great that's not true
that's not true I gotta ask you about
our girl Miley she's coming out with new
music this year this week I excited I
know
Miley is when I'm like one of her
biggest fans and I feel like she got
crazy for a minute there and we're she's
one of the most talented singers in the
world her voice is heaven and I just
have a feeling this is gonna be like
this gonna be good what do you think of
this new era I'll never forget the one
time I saw her sing Jolene at Clive
Davis's pre-grammy party and that was
the first time that I actually really
heard her sing like Matt and I said what
is that voice in that girl she looks
like a some Lucky Charms box but but
like you take all that away and she has
like an epic amazing voice like she's so
talented so sometimes it can be
distracting as a lot of good sparkles
and you know ding-dongs
[Music]
you